the numbers are just hard to grasp a new
assessment from the Federal Emergency
Management Agency leaked to us media
says the United States will have 200,000
new coronavirus cases every day by the
end of this month and as many as three
thousand dead every day by June first
but now the focus is on plans to reopen
the economy California allowing some
retail and manufacturing and New York
making plans to move forward you open
businesses first that are most essential
and pose the lowest risk okay most
essential and the lowest risk phase one
we're talking about construction
manufacturing and select retail with
curbside pickup they are the most
essential with the lowest risk the US
Senate is back to work despite the fact
that it's doctor said it didn't have
enough tests for the 100 senators they
aren't planning on taking up legislation
just confirmations to executive posts
and judges to the bench at the moment
the Republican leader has scheduled no
significant kovat related business for
the floor of the Senate
tonight we will vote on a nomination to
the Nuclear Regulatory Commission well
the Senate isn't taking up a new relief
package the Treasury Department is
trying to find a way to pay for the last
ones announcing it would borrow almost
three trillion dollars and the Supreme
Court went to work in a way that it has
never done in its history honourable the
Chief Justice and the associate justices
of the Supreme Court of the United
States
oyez oyez oyez it heard arguments on the
phone it's expected to hear 10 cases
over the next two weeks the country
finding ways to move forward while
acknowledging there will likely be a
high price to pay for it patty :
al-jazeera